You may have heard the news.
That's right!
[Dramatic pause]
I'm broke.
But thanks to many fellow patreons,
We managed to gather four thousand dollars.
To help...
myself! (you're welcome pewds)
Although for legal reasons,
I couldn't keep any of the money...
which means, I'm back on square zero!
I got nothing, (you got slippy the toad)
nada,
ingenting!
So what do you do when all hope fails?
What do you do before I was pewdiepie?
Thats right selling hot dogs( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Alot of you have know this, some of you may have not.
but before I did youtube I sold hot dogs.
It is in fact my specialty it is what the best thing and only thing i know except for screaming and acting like a retard on the internet.
Little windy for a grill some would say.
Amatures..
I would say back.
You got a grill like this you gotta have balls.
ssss   aaahh!
No no no not the hot dog they will be contaminated!
aaaaaaagh!
Oh boy.
Get them while they are hot.
Hot dogs! hot dogs..
want a hot dog,
Do you like it?
It's good, its good yea?
Thank you very much!
Can I buy your reviews on Yelp ?
That shit cold.
Hotdog?
HOT DOG HGOT DOG HOT DOG, DO YOU WANT A HOT DOG?
Hot doog
[SINGS] ohhh its a wonderfull day...
to do a hot...
WHAT YOU DOING!
COME BACK HERE!
Hot dog?
Lady want a hot dawwwwg?
Baby wana hot dooog?
no one wants a hot dawwwwg? [LAUGHS]
fresh hotdawwwgs,
Hot dog man? You lookin' hungry..
Dinner time..
I feel really bad that no one is buying Felix's putrid hot dogs,
So i gonna humor him and gonna buy a hot dog..
eeeeee felix, pewdiepie..
Uh... I'll buy I'll buy a hotdog.
I'll buy a hotdog..
Oh...
Ok you can have a hot dog.
Thank you..
So how's the buisness goin'?
Oh no It's...
This is not a...
im just doing it for fu.....
is this like a full time thing now or?
It's a... It's a... It's a hobby, I...
Ye? Ye.
Oh wait actually PJ...
Ye?
I have a... Uh... Since your..
a loyal costumer..
Loyal?
You get my special hotdog..
[MAGICAL MUSIC]
Slippy?
It's alive...
Poisonous toad that's alive..
Can i borrow your po.. Your poisonous glands?
Is this sexual harassment?
And I put it back where it belongs,
For da vip's.
[MAGICAL MUSIC]
Here you go PJ.
Hey thanks man...
Wow, you really did it with the ketchup too.
Ketchup there, Thanks man, I appreciate appreciate.
wwwait...
Can you leave a good review?
Uh... Yes.
Best review alright...
Thank you...
Good luck! Enjoy!
[MUSIC]
Hot dawg??
Does anyone want a hotdog?
Thank you very much!
Your a VIP now.
I have to sell my most prized possession,
My... My golden plaque.
Is anyone on the bus?
This is a real golden plaque, It's my last.. version.
It's yours for... A pound.
I'll buy it. Okay cool! Great!
Thank you! I'll give you £5.
Thank you very much!
Anytime mate... Appreciate it.
It's yours. [TAP]
Thank you very much! [REPEAT]
Thanks Felix!
Have a good one.
I got 5 pounds.
It's a new bill too, I really like this. This is great!
His f****** going... [LAUGHS] He actually bought it.
I don't know he keep walking
Bag. [LAUGH CONTINUES]
[ENDING MUSIC]